just a reminder I am still gay as hell
thank you I'm great at it I appreciate
it
yeah I was just sitting there you know
one day just you know being black I look
you know what
give me another thing I got it I can
handle it yeah I am also an immigrant
because I always want the news to be
about me you know my family came to
America from Africa in 1985 back when I
was just a little diva and it was also
the first time I ever saw a white person
and my immediate thought was it's a
black ghost
mother be wary this country's filth
apparitions yes i i'm a black gay
immigrant that's a lot of adjectives
lots unpack but to be honest I don't
feel unique
I believe there's way too much
commonality amongst us that we don't
recognize like I know for a fact that
everyone here has an enemy list we all
do we all have at least one person if
they don't show up to the world tomorrow
will believe in God again I'm just like
you I'm no different I have an enemy
list it's very short very concise list
the first person on this list is a
gentleman that offered me a cookie but
then he had me a Fig Newton those two
things aren't comparable close your eyes
imagine a cookie
is anyone here thinking of a nasty brick
of fiber with grotesque jelly in the
middle
that's not a cookie the second person on
this list is um my friend's mother she
would mix Nesquik with water yo that's
mud that is nasty sugary ass mud she
even tried to convince us once that
Crystal Light was kool-aid I'm like lady
you got it go never than ask Paris but
the last person on this list is a very
special person has anyone here a fan of
the wonderful world of Harry Potter
i I love Harry Potter I love Harry
Potter so much I went all the way to
Orlando Florida a butthole of a city
I went to Universal Studios Florida to
go to Harry Potter world one of the best
days of my life
I got a wall I got a wand I wore a cloak
no one stopped me because I'm a
grown-ass man and I was having such a
great day until I met this individual it
was a Harry Potter world employee yeah
and he called me called me a muggle to
my entire face yes for those of you are
not familiar a muggle is a derogatory
term for a non-magical person in the
world of Harry Potter and I did not
spend $150 to have a white teenager call
me the N word of the Wizarding World
I was only asking for directions to the
bathroom and he responded with well sir
the muggle restroom is down the corridor
and I replied young man you work in a
theme park in Florida spell corridor
[Applause]
you